I remember I was in Italy I saw a
ladybug and I was like this ladybug has
no idea it's
Italian has no idea it's Italian how
many [__] things are we carrying
around and who are you when you drop
them and which of those things are
undroppable you wouldn't believe what
you believe you wouldn't believe what
you believe and what you believe you'll
take it because the zero of no buiness
is is so uncomfortable that you'd rather
be angry than
happy
[Music]
Pete Holmes is one of my very favorite
humans and today he returns to the
podcast to share what I think is his
truly unique gift which is this great
ability that he has to weave the
hilarious and confusing experiences of
of just being alive with the big
mystical and philosophical questions
about what it all means he is a veteran
standup comedian you might know him from
from his HBO show crashing which he
created with friend of the Pod Jud appow
you might know him from his recent CBS
sitcom Howe roll or his great podcast
you made it weird maybe you read his
Memoir comedy sex god or seen him in one
of his many late night appearances or
comedy specials the latest of which is
called I'm not for everyone and it drops
on Netflix October 24th today we go kind
of all over the place we talk about
consciousness optimis M parenting
spirituality of course we discuss diet
we talk about the nature of reality
fatherhood the many disorientations of
midlife it kind of sounds like a big hot
mess but actually it all ties together
beautifully and I think you're going to
really love it as Pete likes to say get
into
it I think the last time we did this was
that was before your how how old is your
daughter five now yeah five yeah she'll
be five in September but yeah yeah how
has that changed things for you in all
the good ways and all the best ways uh
comedians run a real risk at being very
self-centered I think we all do but
comedians maybe especially so having a
daughter has made me take myself a lot a
lot less seriously and having something
outside of me and also a unit like a
family unit that I care about more than
my career I I found this balance how has
that influenced or affected your
relationship with spirituality because
I'm thinking on the one hand you have
this tiny helpless being and with that
you just become infused with awe and
wonder and all the joy and and you know
experience of of of love that comes with
that but at the same time it's [__]
hard right and it it it doesn't I
wouldn't say it's a recipe for bringing
out your best self like you're tired
you're stressed you're like you know
what I mean like yeah
yeah I mean okay so Leonard Cohen said
the cracks are how the light gets
through and I think about that all the
time with Leela and obviously my ego
what Pete wants is to always be perfect
but sometimes when my daughter is
complaining and throwing a fit honestly
that a song that doesn't exist doesn't
exist she'll say tell Spotify to play
the Unicorn Hot Air Balloon song right
I'm like sweetheart that song doesn't
exist because she doesn't know what
songs are she's just like do it and I'm
like well a person writes you know you
tell this this you know like disembodied
uh thing to do something and it does why
it doing yeah so she's screaming she's
having some other she's you know she's
stapling another amendment to this issue
and she's working something out
emotionally and in those moments you
know I'm very proud to be doing better
than the generations before us there's
no harsh language or anything you know
punitive but sometimes I'll be like
Leela you know it's enough enough and
she's so sensitive that she like a rly
poy she'll just curl up and I you just
feel terrible just for saying sometimes
calmly Leela my daughter got mad at me
yes yesterday because she was on my back
and she was choking me and I went
sweetheart you're choking me she was mad
that I told her to stop choking me like
hurt cuz she just wants me to be a
playground so there's no avoiding it
that's what I've learned in fact that's
what they're doing is they're kind of
they want to figure out limits and
figure out the relationship and all that
stuff so it's normal I have to
disappoint her I have to so that's
humbling and that's good but then what
my wife Val has helped me understand and
give language to is it's all in the
repair right so I go Leela that's enough
and she kind of curls up and I feel bad
but then like and I'm
driving I do what I always fantasized
would be done to me this is what we do
in reparenting ourselves I just put my
hand on her and I just go sweetheart are
you upset because data um what what is
the language I use I don't say lost my
temper but something like that m is it
because I got um aggravated and she goes
yeah and I go even if I'm upset I always
say the same thing I go you're always
safe you're loved and um you're good MH
I think beautiful those are the three
things right that we all kind of want to
hear beautiful so I go you're safe
you're loved you're good and and that
moment so I didn't want the failure
but it's not even a failure but I didn't
want
that and I used to be able to avoid
those more easily because I didn't have
children but it's on the other side of
that foyble or or vulnerability on both
of our parts that there's this beautiful
she put her hand on my hand and just
started like singing and cing it was
it's how the world works I'm working on
a new bit about the reason why the fish
walked out of the ocean they grew legs
is because the as that hit the planet
and killed all the dinosaurs this is a
theory obviously made the water so
radioactive that they had to it wasn't
just curiosity they had to I relate to
that leaving home when things get too
toxic you know what I mean it gets it
gets fried and they walk out so we're
born on the backs of catastrophe you and
me are the effects of catastrophe and we
walk around going like why can't things
be perfect yeah which is crazy there's a
line at Coffee being what is this
[__] I'm like you're here because
something from space wiped out the
entire planet and and we forget that
that's how it works I lose my temper and
then there's a greater love in the the
rewelding it's better the scar is better
than having no wounds at all it's a
constant uh action or or or practice of
recovering from catastrophe to this idea
of reparenting right like you were
parented in a certain way you you walk
around with your wounds promising to
yourself that when you have a child
you're not going to make these mistakes
and you do your best you screw up in
moments of stress you probably behave
exactly the way your parents did um but
you recover more quickly and you have
healthier language to you know mend that
and and hopefully not leave your leave
your child scarred but I'm curious
around the the weaker moments where you
see glimpses of your parents and how
that affects how you relate to them like
are you able to be I just know as a
parent like oh like I tried so hard to
not do that thing and now and I'm
repeating that exact thing yeah because
it's so deeply embedded you can catch
yourself but you know what it's done for
me is it it made me appreciate sort of a
hierarchy of needs thing right where I
really feel like my parents were growing
up in a time very firmly I feel like
they were growing up in I I picture it
like sepat toned everyone's wearing news
these caps and there was just like more
fighting for your supper at their in
their lives not everybody's life
necessarily but with my father and my
mother they just didn't have the maybe
what they would call the naval gazy time
to go like who am I right what kind of a
they also thought their kids kind of
belonged to them if you want a really
far out thing I don't think my daughter
belongs to me I also don't think I
brought her into this world if you
really want to get super woo but like if
my daughter wasn't here in this daughter
it should be somewhere else my parents
my dad is like you know I made you it's
like no you did you didn't climb up into
my mom's womb with spackle you know what
I mean you gave the isness a vessel to
continue this play with itself but like
when you don't have that ownership over
your daughter that that that took some
of that Naval gazy time to have that
sort of respect for her autonomy and
maybe my parents you know didn't have as
much of that but it's because they were
fight fighting for a tunel right the the
the top of that on my mind um the maslo
hierarchy of needs like they're not
pondering you know their their their
broader you know spiritual relationship
with the universe because life is
[__] hard and you know what I was
just talking about this with my friend I
was like the time that we used to drive
to CVS to develop our film would take
film and drive it wait in line drop it
off drive back a week later drive back
wait in line pick it up drive home look
at your pictures so let's say that's two
hours um now I have a phone I just take
it on my phone and the the pictures are
done so what am I doing with those two
hours well taking mushrooms and you know
medita or whatever it might be so of
course but I see everything kind of co-
conspiring to move human consciousness
forward that might be my optimism I'm
like this thing in my view is arcing to
use everything the scars The Good The
Bad The Suffering The Darkness the light
it's all even something is super
superficial as a phone is kind of saving
us time wherein you might ask yourself
an important question like who am I but
the problem with that is We Can't Stop
scrolling in order to take advantage of
that added time we feel it you know I
feel I feel that and I also see that as
the bow string being pulled back meaning
we're in this kind of awful time where
like we're all fighting the urge to be
entertained in and like my wife goes up
to the baby cried last night the baby
she's F but you know she was crying in
bed and Mama ran up to get her and we
were watching the big Labowski and as
she ran upstairs I immediately swapped
over to YouTube and just watched like
some clip like I just looked for
something that was like short and just
watched it uh yeah so I get it we're
we're [__] ourselves and it's it's a
problem but I also see that in that
tension and in this not working you know
what I mean the things that don't work
constantly entertaining ourselves const
over stimulating over learning over
everything when it doesn't work that's
another crack that the light gets
through in fact I think that's a deeply
important spiritual lesson is [__]
doesn't work Fame doesn't work money
doesn't work sex doesn't work drugs
don't work whatever you take your pick
and at the end of that harrowing Journey
that Western culture told you would work
when it doesn't work that Brokenness is
a is a Launchpad to look for what is
consistent what is sustaining me who
what who am I really cuz it's not just
this MH gobble monster cuz that doesn't
work so the doesn't work is how work
works this is another asteroid crashing
into the planet content addiction
doesn't work asteroid Planet dinosaurs
fish with foot fish with feet is you
walking out and going this sucks I'm not
happy yeah I mean this is the story of
my life I relate to that deeply every
grow spurt that I've ever had has been
catalyzed by you being in tremendous
pain or banging my head against the wall
in a way that you know eventually I
realize it's not going to work but I
also see people out in the world who are
you know maybe not alcoholics but drink
a lot and will until they hit the grave
because it never becomes a big enough
problem or they can scroll on their
phones and it's not disrupting their
life adequately enough for them to ever
take inventory of it and I think those
are the people ultimately that are
robbed of the miracle and are stuck in
the in the kind of you know miasma
because
they never reach that you know they
don't they don't hit bottom or they
don't they're never faced with an
adequate am amount of pain to yeah to
change their life right that's why like
in in recovery it's like I'm grateful
you know it's like the Grateful
alcoholic the pretty it's like all these
things that happened to me created a
situation in which I then became open to
a new way of being and doing where I
could set aside my ego I could ask for
help receive help um entertain a new
possibility uh you know how to how to
organize my life and and like broaden my
perspective to you know Ponder spiritual
principles to drive my decisions yeah
it's asteroid hitting the planet and
it's it's also the the story of Christ
is death death going too far we we we
shouldn't have gone to Jerusalem in you
for in your case I mean you had this
divorce which was really painful but
it's not like I'm sure it was awful but
it's also a very common experience it's
not like your entire life fell no if I
was at the buffet of tra I would pick
it's pretty B 28y old divorce with no
kids but in your specific set of Life
circumstances that was enough and talk
okay grateful alcohol grateful divorce a
like I I thank whatever you got to thank
I'll thank it for that happening at that
time and this this is what we're saying
with the asteroid propelling the fish
out of the leg I I mean we need that and
what you're really teaching me is the
danger of the middle you know what I
mean I'm not saying you should like go
hard with alcohol just so you can become
an alcoholic and hit the bottom but like
we need to get in the mix you know like
even after my marriage I had a lot of or
several relationships friendships and
romantic relationships that were just
like oh I'm re I'm unconsciously
reenacting trauma that I haven't
processed so I'm looking for the same
toxicity pattern in these people and
through that process and those were
worse than my divorce some of these
relationships were worse than my divorce
they're not as splashy cuz there's no
legal there's no paperwork but you're
getting like pushed to the point if you
watch my first Conan I'm like 285 or
something look not that weight is the
thing I'm just saying for me it was the
thing I was drinking constantly eating
constantly CU I was trying to put
insulation around wounds unprocessed
Trauma from my childhood from all sorts
of places and it wasn't working and if
you watch my first con and I'm like 285
my second time I'm on Cone and I'm 235
and that was like a juice fast and all
this stuff it came from Pain it came
from okay you didn't figure out in your
family well here's the same Dynamic
written all caps in a relationship now
you know now you're in the mud looking
for a knife to stand up for yourself I
don't mean violence I mean like now
you're forced you either let this thing
break you or you say like you know what
actually I'm lovable I'm good I'm safe
I'm loved and then you meet somebody
like Valerie that's my wife those
relationships that that broke broke me
and hurt me if I hadn't had those I
wouldn't have found Valerie cuz I never
would have been putting out
right vibration right um some people are
just capable of reading something or
hearing something or seeing something
and going that's a good idea I think I'm
going to do that no pain I I don't know
who those people are I don't know how
that works but there are those people do
walk the earth I know they are among us
and I don't understand them either dude
I I wanted to tell you this cuz I I've
been doing something called the 52 diet
have you heard of that it's two days a
week you fast you you it's a fast oh
yeah do know that yeah yeah yeah Kimmel
did it um and it just never made sense
to me in fact Kimmel did my podcast he's
explaining it to me his friend Daniel
Daniel kellison also did it and was
explaining it to me and I was just like
what know mean two days of not eating
it's two days of intermittent fasting on
two of those days no it's it's not
intermittent it's on two days you eat
1/4 of your calories so it's for me cuz
I'm 3200 is my whatever BMI I can do 800
I try to do five 500 or between 5 and
600 calories on two days a week um and
most of the time you're just not eating
and I was like that's insane then I go
home this is weird I wasn't I wanted to
tell you about the fasting thing because
that's kind of in your wheelhouse and I
I'm a huge fan if you want to talk about
it but what propelled it the why of it
was because I went home this is [__]
up I was swimming with my dad I took my
shirt off and he he made a joke about my
body m
and he was joking I sinc we've had a
talk about it since I sincerely don't
think he meant to hurt me but some of us
win loser draw the way I'm wired is pain
it's like [__] like fertilizer is
actually way better for me it like a
little bit of Shame little bit of [__]
you I'm not I'm not proud of this I'm
not even selling it I'm just telling you
what happened the day he said that to me
and hurt my feelings I think I think the
next day I started and I fasted and
there is Spite and there is resentment
and there like there all this nasty
[__] [__] but I think there's
something to going like look I can't
change I wish I could I can't change
some of my fundamental programming but I
can lean into it and as long as it's
healthy meaning I'm not abusing myself
if I can get motivation out of it I will
cuz I I'm not in the motivation store
picking and choosing yeah well you got
to take and grab willingness wherever
you can find it right because
willingness is hard to come by and it's
something you can't instill in other
people and it's hard to talk yourself
into it on your own so if it comes in
the form of some kind of negative you
know trauma induced experience there's
still a diamond in there and I think you
know for someone like yourself who's
undergone many changes over the course
of his life I would suspect that you're
able to recognize like oh here's a
moment yeah I feel that willingness yeah
yeah I'm pissed at my dad but like I can
do something with this because last time
I felt like this I did this and I
remember I changed my life by doing this
and I'm going to leverage that in the
same way and I think it's doing it
consciously meaning if you can stand
calmly beside the berserk guy in your
psyche who is so mad and has the knife
from the mud it's like ah and you go
he's not steering the car but I can use
some of his heat to do something
positive the worst thing you can do for
me is tell me like sometimes people have
said like oh P you lost some weight I'm
like please don't say that because then
I'll think I'm done yeah right I like
you do look good though apprciate I
watched your your new special you've
definitely lost a lot of weight from
that I don't know when you tape
thato okay yeah that I taped that a
couple months ago but this this um first
of all I don't know the trick of the
fasting diet so it's a fasting mimicking
diet cuz if you're eating 500 calories
you'd be surprised you you can get a lot
of protein and stuff that fills you up
with that little calories but the trick
is you do it because you want to lose
weight or I did and be healthy and give
your body time to repair but the sneak
the like The Sleeper Cell in there is
that it's slowly reprogramming I I'm
like I struggle with like food addiction
it's reprogramming how you think about
food so if two days a week you're
basically not eating you see how good it
feels to be clean because you're really
only eating like very basic stuff and
are you like on a program for what those
foods are is it pre-prepared or on your
own on that it's pretty it's pretty
simple it's you know it's like maybe
I'll do smoothies or just trying to get
as many nutrients and as much protein as
I can keeping the calories low but then
the next day so yesterday was a fast day
for me today is a a feed day you'd think
I'd get up and eat a cake right but this
[__] thing tricks you and you go
godamn it well you have momentum and you
feel good and you don't want to you
don't want to you know once you have a
little bit of traction yes you know it's
easier to keep it going and you start
retraining your brain what actually
feels good and being lean and clean like
simple feels really really good and the
way that it works is when you're fasting
you go I can eat it tomorrow and that's
that's all I need
if you say like for 30 days we're not
eating I'm like [__] off like you're not
the boss of me that's actually the voice
of my food addict it's like you're not
the boss of me and I'll eat a bowl of
pasta just despite it but if this thing
tricks you and goes you can eat a whole
Bowl Posta tomorrow and then the next
day you wake up and you don't feel like
it you're like [__] you dad like it's a
trick right well that's that's the whole
premise of 12ep too just like it's just
for today right you want to drink just
drink tomorrow it's cool just hit the
hit the pillow tonight sober the problem
with this like me the addict in me is
like oh I feel so good like fasting yeah
um yeah I can eat whatever I want
tomorrow but I'll just I'll just well
I'll just I'll go I'll fast three days
you know instead of two and then three
becomes four and then suddenly I have
like a weird disordered eating kind of
situation and I have to look out for
that I I ran into that a little when I
was doing um what is it like I was
eating in an 8 Hour window uh-huh
intermittent fasting yeah and that it's
so complicated these days yeah it
[__] food there's a lot we need to
eat it there's we need to eat it that's
why I like just knowing like Monday
Thursday take it off and you you do lose
a lot of weight are you still you were
vegan for a while are you still vegan or
are you have you I've started eting some
fish yeah you hurt me a little bit of
fish R I'm sorry Little Fish Little Fish
yeah it's mostly it had something to do
with having a baby it it doesn't you
know what sucks about being a a former
vegan is you know why you should be a
vegan it sucks right like every time you
eat that fish yeah no it sucks my face
is haunting you yeah no your face my own
face you know the The Sweet Spot is to
never do the
research you know what I mean the
ethical research all of it the way that
is far if you don't know and you just
stay in that sort of blissful ignorance
that's nice but if you once I had a baby
and she was doing formula which you know
we had Dairy cuz whatever other things
and then next thing you know she's
eating pizza I'm just kind of stealing a
bite of her Pizza like I just wasn't
taking myself as seriously like me as
seriously it's not even a good excuse
but it it just kind of started to
unravel a little bit yeah we're going to
have to talk about that a little bit
more I'd love to know I mean I also
started lifting weights and a lot of
people were like this is I'm talking to
the perfect person they were they were
like you know the best protein they were
like wayy protein is better I was like
but it's all this dairy in they like
there's no dairy in the lactose is taken
out tell me tell me it's fine I I the
protein thing is is very overblown it's
it's not that hard to build lean muscle
mass on a plant-based diet I mean that's
sort of the old Trope that is easy to
throw around but yeah uh has never been
my experience and I know like vegan
bodybuilders and I know people that have
never eaten meat their entire Lives who
look like machines in the gym so it's
not and and then oh it's so complicated
then you have to you know be planning
all your meals it's it's really never
been that way for me I mean it's I've
been doing this for 16 years yeah um and
and I and I conscious to eat more
protein I'm like turning 57 next month
like the older you get like you have to
be you know intaking more because you
start to lose your muscle mass so I'm a
little more conscious of that and I'm in
the gym more than I used to be when I
was just out running all the time but
but um it's it's it's not like an
insurmountable problem or hurdle I want
I'd love to hear your response on this I
remember cuz Rick Ruben was a vegan and
then he stopped yeah and that had
something to do with it yeah but but
okay go this is what he said I want to
hear I want to hear all of it I'm gonna
stop talking but he was like it's the
all carb diet that was what he said what
do we got tell me I love Rick Ruben um
but if you listen to him talk about what
he was actually eating on a vegan diet
it's easy to understand why he gained
weight like I think it's he was a bread
vegan if you eat just tons of refined
carbs and it's never been easier to be a
junk food vegan you can eat a horrible
diet on a vegan diet and delude yourself
into believing that you're doing
something healthy for yourself because
it doesn't have animal products in it
but that doesn't mean that it's healthy
or moving you in the right direction oil
yeah and so if you start eating animal
products which are more calorically
dense and like sort of quoti to it
you'll feel full and you probably won't
be eating as much junk whereas if you're
eating a plant-based diet you have to
find like you know whole foods that are
close to their natural state and avoid
all of the processed foods that are out
there and all the products that um they
finally figured out how to make taste
adequately okay you know coconut ice
cream and all these you know products
that um are are good if you're getting
into it for sustainability reasons or
for you know compassionate reasons
exactly um but it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's healthy so yeah you know
uh well I love this cuz I do deal with
cognitive dissonance and listen when you
have a when you have a when you have a
small child like it's harder you know
like your life is more complicated and
you're tired and when you're tired
you're going to reach for the thing
that's less healthy yeah yeah yeah yeah
I I'm in a weird place because of that
meaning it just sort of started
happening and then it just was easier
and now like anything exactly but
actually it wasn't just sloth it was
like simple I was like I'll just grill a
piece of fish and have some broccoli and
I'm done is easier than like yeah I
understand piecing it together no I I
I'm not I have no judge I'm not judging
you at all you don't believe in the
suffering of animals including me I know
you don't either so so I guess I would
just say knowing what you know because
you've lived this lifestyle before
yeah there's a dissonance like a like a
very low grade hum right where you know
like this isn't necessarily in the
highest alignment with who the person
that I'd like to be no and there's a
there's a lightness or a sense of
Freedom that comes when you can correct
that alignment that's true and I might
be deluding myself but I do catch myself
not judging other people which was a
thing for me I'm not saying for you but
when I was when you when you're a vegan
and you feel like you're opting out of
the suffering
it's not really true no of course not
and I think I it's not in service to the
vegan movement for vegans to be on their
high horse judging other people like we
all you know just by Dent of living on
planet Earth we are tapping its
resources and
and house for an hour there's and and
you know the food that you're eating
there's a cost to all of it like nobody
is living on the planet without creating
suffering right right so at least
acknowledge that and you know maybe step
back from all the
judgmentalism that that only alienates
other people anyway right right yeah
you're you're I'm not even proud of this
but I have caught myself being like I'm
just being honest like this whole thing
is brutal and I'm just like and I'm just
I'm just in it there's sort of like a
this is what I mean it's not as airtight
as being like how could a sentient thing
and the suffering and factory farming
and all this stuff the best I can come
up with and I'm not saying I like it
it's just going like it's what it's
what's happening I know I and I that's I
do suffer because of this I'm telling
you knowing happen for this phone in my
hand to be in my hand like how many
people had to suffer for this to exist
or the battery that's in my car or the
diey that was the runoff uh from the
t-shirt that I'm wearing you know how
how many fish died because of that like
it you know when you really telescope up
and and try to look at our consumer
choices holistically we're all wreaking
havoc and and we can tread a little bit
more lightly yeah and we can all do
better but I think when you refrain from
judging other people on their decisions
you create uh an opening or a sense of
welcomeness in which we can have a
productive dialogue about how we can all
do better yeah not by pointing fingers
at other people and judging them but by
acknowledging our own fallibility and
and you know
imperfections I think that's well
I do hate it people used to come when I
was a vegan they'd be like well you know
when they're farming the almonds they
suck up rodents or whatever it is well
there's I mean it's just there's always
a whataboutism well you know what is
there just is a heartbreak to this
reality that you were just touching on
and I think what's annoying for lack of
a better word is there's no way to opt
out of it entirely and I think that
leads to a certain defeatism that people
go like well you can't win so you might
as well eat some chicken truth true but
like every change in the world starts
with people changing their minds about
things right every big change every
social change every Revolution started
with one person doing something
different like I think we we actually do
have a lot more agency and for someone
like yourself who is in front of
audiences and talking behind a
microphone for for many many years like
you have the power to influence a lot of
people
and I think when you're a certain and
living in a certain way there's there's
a there's real potency to that that can
change people I think you're right I'm
telling you I'm over here but I'm not
I'm not like you should come to my side
do you want to feel conflicted most
meals get over here it's great it's
great and and and people say why and you
just go just kind of lazy it feels
awesome come over here you
devil you watch a special you know I did
you're one of the few people that have
seen it I know thank you for sharing it
with me when is it coming out end of
October okay cool congrats it's super
funny thanks man yeah I really um you've
come a long way man you've been doing
this for a
while yeah God it's been like 22 years
or something and now I'm working on my
new hour I mean I feel like so you're
this hour isn't even out yet this
special and you're already cracking the
next one I have the next one I was just
talking to Neil brenon I was like I have
the time you wouldn't call it an hour
until it's really polished and sort of
interwoven and tight and sort of
thematically clumped and stuff I have
the time and it's starting to get woven
together the you know the callbacks and
the interrelatedness of the bits are
it's starting to present itself but this
is the I just did Denver Comedy Works uh
like two weeks ago and I did this new
hour not the one that's going to air at
the end of October but there is a new
hour and I'm like what I was going to
say is I think you can relate to this as
one of the great secrets to Joy on the
human plane not in like any spiritual or
super meaning of life way but just in
like the bread and butter daytoday how
to be a happy human having some
infinitely playable game for you I think
it's ultramarathon you know like the
athletic there is something if you allow
athletic about doing a new hour you're
you're trying it you're testing it
you're risking you might be risking
injury I'm risking like psych
psychological injury humiliation and
that really motivates you like you if
you have sorry to force this but like if
you have a race coming up you train
because you know you have this race when
I have a weekend coming up I write
because I know I have and I and I I have
a show tonight because I have a show
this weekend got to work it out so when
people like struggle with writing their
novel or whatever I'm like yeah no [__]
there's no pit of spikes and Flames
beneath you like I'll suffer pain
tonight if I don't do my homework right
if you had to get up and read a chapter
from your novel once a week or whatever
yeah yeah that would help that would
help like put it and David sedarius and
other people like that do that but like
if you're just wondering why you're
sitting around tinker on a screenplay
I'm like because there's no risk yeah
like stand up is like a treadmill if you
stop you fall off you know what I mean
it's not it's not running in the woods
where you can just start walking and no
one knows you didn't hit your
goal walk me through your creative
process from how you're finding ideas
how you're remembering these ideas
working on them how does that how does
that work for you well well it's it's
very different 23 years in at the
beginning you're like trying to write
jokes like what will make people laugh
and now that I'm in my 40s and I've been
doing it a long time a bit presents
itself when you when something comes up
and you have a very strong feeling like
there should be some word in Greek for
it or something like there's this
feeling that you know I really have
strong thoughts and perspectives about
this and I feel surefooted in my
thoughts even if it's something as
stupid as Q-tips I I have a very strong
feeling about Q-tips not I know I can
make that funny necessarily but you look
for the the passion feeling first and
then you go on stage and you kind of
play with it you you know I don't write
it so when that occurs to you though do
you like open up your phone and write it
in a note or do you do a voice memo like
what is the Practical I text myself a
lot because there's something about
being in the car that takes over your
your you know your body so your brain is
kind of free to wander so I'm text I'm
sending myself a lot of crazy texts
saying text Pete Holmes what do you want
to say to Pete Holmes Q-tips is acting
like they don't know we're putting these
things in our
ears and it goes your text to Pete
Holmes says Q-tips act like they don't
and you're just like a crazy person and
then you have sort of the outline so
nowhere is it written down necessarily
like what you're actually going to say
but but like then I go on stage with an
idea like that and I tried the Q-tip
joke it's very funny to talk about a
silly joke seriously but I was on stage
a couple nights ago and it just came out
I was like uh something like when are
the people at Q-tips going to stop
gaslighting us like they don't know
we're putting these shits in our ears
right CU it says like don't put it in
your ear right it does but also on the
back it has the balls to say it's for
first aid I'm like who the and this is
just coming out cuz I care I go who is
the lunatic putting neopor on a Q-tip
and then putting it on their no one no
one is doing that and then the second
one is U makeup and then I'm like surely
the third one will be cram it in your
ear the third one is clean your keyboard
and I was like what [__] nonsense is
this they know we're rotating touching
the brain getting that ear G-spot and
it's just coming out because I care and
it's like then then you know the comic
and you looks for that's like you want
like that that's like Coca-Cola being
like this is a product to dissolve teeth
in you guys are drinking it like but but
even the word gaslighting now we're
laughing about family Dynamics like the
way that this is just a human thing
we're going to
ignore reality there's a corporation
just ignoring reality they have meetings
I was like do they draw the blinds and
put the Q-tips in there you're like a
like secret like like that's an area
where I feel like there's a joke at
whereas when I was starting I was like
what's the employee discount at the
dollar store that's a good joke but like
now I'm looking for those things that
I'm like I can't stop talking about how
Q-tips is [__] lying right but then
you have the theme emerging from that
which is like the the mass delusion of
humanity right and so you can use that
to tie different bits together and
create something coherent out of the
whole thing well here's the other thing
that I I I thought you might think is
interesting when you've been doing a 23
years you start stealing from yourself
so I'm putting together a new hour and
you're and you're like let's say I have
a joke about um Q-tips and then you're
like that that I wish I had a joke here
and then you remember you do you've
never done it you never recorded it and
maybe you wrote it in your first three
years of standup when you were bad but
the thought had a kernel in there that
was good now you're doing what I call
old new it's new to them and you might
rework it but you're stealing it's a
great feeling when you of journals
though that you've been keeping for
years that you go back and find those
things or you just remember Oh I thought
about that many years ago a lot of it
just kicks around in the brain yeah I'm
not go I'm not I do have journals for my
early years but like most of it just
kind of goes like oh yeah or somebody
says something and I go who has a joke
about that I'm like I do it's a
wonderful feeling you start to become
like a I don't know like there's someone
else working in there how often are you
going up
okay well I'm glad you asked because at
this point in my life and this is
something I'm very passionate about when
you're starting comedy you go up like
every night right or you want to and and
then you do and sometimes you go up
multiple times a night and then you go
out every weekend and you're just
constantly working and and that's like
20 years or or 10 years maybe like the
first six maybe you're not working
because nobody wants you to work then
there's the middle portion this 10 years
of hitting it really hard and now I'm in
the second part or third
part and not a lot of comics are talking
about this and I'd really like to go on
the record that there's a third phase
which is like a balance phase where
you're trying to get the levels just
right and and instead of mimicking other
people's processes you start honoring
and valuing your own so I do a monthly
show at Largo where I do an hour that's
the bulk of my standup in a month to get
ready for that maybe I'll go and perform
at the comedy
store once a month maybe twice a month
and like tonight I'm doing Dynasty
typewriter because I'm working this
weekend so I just want to reheat the
hour but like most of the time there's
like writing down notes and jotting
stuff up it's taking advantage of all of
this work that I've put in to be have a
comic mind and trust that when I'm on
stage it will come out appropriately and
then most of my life the greatest
compliment my wife gave me people say
what's it like being married to a
comedian and she's like I barely notice
that I'm married to a comedian don't get
me wrong we laugh and we're silly but
like it's not this what everyone assumes
it is is that like oh you must be
traveling all the time people are like
how's life on the road people say to me
I'm like I go out one weekend a month
that's it that's three weekends not out
and you know what most people work all
day every day so one weekend a month
condensing all of my work into 3 days
pretty [__] good and nobody's really
comedians are in this great position a
lot of creative people are in this great
position a lot of business people are in
this position like entrepreneurs and
stuff to get those levels just right but
I don't see a lot of people trying to
kind of Tim Ferris it trying to my
friend James Bashar is one of these guys
that's like yeah I just um I only answer
emails on Tuesdays between 10:00 and
noon or whatever and I'm like comedians
should be doing this let's get those
levels right let's not just be Pirates
you know going out and drinking rum and
swimming from ropes all the [__] time
yeah yeah I mean that is The Stereotype
tortured person who's spending all their
time in in the comedy clubs and also in
their in their kind of pedestrian life
everything's a bit they're never just
relaxed and living their life well we
moved up kind of it's funny driving
Heroes like I'm driving home because I
we live in ohigh that was oh that's
right I forgot yeah I felt like I was on
my way
are they are you like Rob Bell's next
door neighbor now Rob does live right up
the street from me and it's [__]
incredible and I really credit Valerie
for that choice like she's this great
counterbalance I'm very fiery and she's
very I I don't know if she's watery but
she balances it out you know and she was
like we love it when we go there I think
we should move there and we did and it
was hard for me to do cuz you can't just
pop down and do a set well I was scared
I was scared I'd vanish yeah I I thought
it would be too far to do shows and then
I'd stop doing shows and then I'd lose
my identity and now what am I just in a
rocking chair like what do I do it's not
been that way at all and for the first
time in my life like I'm not putting
down my comedian friends but Neil
Brennan who is one of my comedian
friends he's like there are no friends
in Show Business he's like we're all
just in a bar fight and sometimes you're
punching in the same direction as the
random guy next to you and it gives the
illusion that you're on the same team
but it's really just a bar fight that
may or may not be true but I will say
now I just have like for the first time
in my life I feel like Bigfoot like
friend like I'm learning what it's like
to have a coffee shop that I go to and
if I'm not there and sometimes I'm not
the next time I'm there people like hey
where were you and I was like well I was
here and they want to know they're not
you know not that all my friends are
doing this but they're not gaming me
they're not we're not talking about
projects and casting or any of that [__]
we're just human beings hanging out and
I've never been happier this time in my
life is the happiest time in my life and
it's because I'm starting to enjoy seeds
in yeah well it's funny that you say
that that was our slogan my own personal
slogan I was like good life when good
life when and you don't have to be a
fancy Show Business jerk like me to do
this there's a lot of our friends
regular work you know what I mean but
they figured out we can do this we can
make it work here we can do
this and it's not just ohigh when people
say like should I move to ohigh I'm like
well first just you got to get your life
[__] right you know what I mean I'm
fulfilled I know what I need to hum and
that's a certain amount of sets in a
month and that's a certain amount of
writing and that's a certain amount of
Performing and creating and I I and I go
okay how much of my life is that okay
maybe that's 18% and then like having a
good marriage our marriage is [__]
great having a daughter our family is
[__] great okay now we can rally this
up and move it somewhere but you can't
just move somewhere and hope it fixes
you you go there there might be a lot of
quiet up there for you to figure out
you're doing some some things not crazy
right right I mean it's a big lifestyle
change for people that don't know for
you you were like living in the heart of
Hollywood right to go to ohigh super
sleepy beautiful place yeah
um yeah the Cadence of life up there I
mean you might as well be living in you
know DEC Illinois or something I'll tell
you just because you kind of live out
here too uh or far from the city is um
not it's so not a problem I I credit it
to having a daughter first of all I
credit it to our life just being right
and everybody being communicative and
honest about their needs you know what I
mean that's huge I didn't know how to do
that in my 20s and now I say I need to
do ASAT like I'm going to do AAP like
you know uh it doesn't even get to that
place they're just in the calendar but
um the drive has become sacred time for
me it's not wasted time at all it's
where I get all my reading done it's
audio books it's where I get all of my
learning done it's where I get all my
phone calls done I'm not talking about
business calls I told you I talked to
Neil Brandon today that was on the ride
down we just talk for 30 minutes I'm
being like a a better friend a more
available friend and not only is it not
a problem I'll drive in I've I've done
this before I'll drive in from ohigh
have a meeting at like 11: drive back
I'm home at
1:30 drive back for a show drive back
I'm home at 11:00 and I'm just like when
I lived in Los FES it wasn't Hollywood
it's Los FES and jud's office when we
were doing crashing was in Santa Monica
it was two hours yeah no one thought
that was crazy so you see these these
delusions that we're all under that we
sort of reflect back to each other if
it's in La what are you talking about
that's own delusion because anyone who
doesn't live in LA would consider that
to be lunacy yeah which it is it is no
all of this is ins and all you're doing
is cutting across town buddy that drive
was worse than the drive up to Ohio all
the time and then I I look at it as like
math it's like when I'm in ohigh to go
to the grocery store five minutes five
American minutes to drop my daughter at
school 10 minutes actually she just
moved school so it's closer we could
walk uh if I'm going anywhere pick
anywhere the the Beach 15 minutes right
in La each one of those would be 45 so
90 round but no I'm not really trying to
sell living in the country as much as
I'm saying like get creative about your
blocks you go like well that's 90
minutes in the car that's ludicrous it's
like yeah but when you go to Whole Foods
here on uh Santa Monica there 45 minutes
shopping 45 minutes but the real block
is is in your mind the the you know the
fear of irrelevance but
opting out being part of that like
hamster wheel living there I actually
appreciate that that is the fear and
there are some people I know that live
up in ohigh that you can feel them
drying out and they're like I'm I just
got to be in the mix I've been done
trying to be in the mix for a while but
I've also been doing it 20 years so
there is a lot of privileges to check
here and one of them is a career
privilege where I'm like I can stack my
Monday I did my pod or it's Tuesday but
I did my podcast this morning I'll do
this with you I have dinner with my
friend I'll do a show tonight
not a lot of people can go hey Rich when
can we do it let's do it on this day hey
hey Dynasty typewriter I want to do a
show on this night can we do it there's
there's a lot of things in line but I
also just talk to the other side I know
a lot of people that have way more
access way more money way more power
whatever you want to call it that aren't
doing this so you know yeah no you've
you've consciously carved out this
really unique career I mean
congratulations for moving out and
enjoying it I think it's great like if
we're not going to enjoy our lives now
when are we going to do it right and to
have that awareness um is a credit to
you and to the work that you've done on
yourself and in just reflecting upon
your career it's super unique because on
the one hand you're standup like Neil
Brennan and John meany and all those
guys that I know you're friends with um
you also have this television career
like you're now you're like turning into
a sitcom guy like you went from crashing
and you did that bowling show and uh to
know in like Night Court like what is
going
on doing all these shows that's a whole
conversation I know but put a pin in
that for now um so you have that side of
your career then you have the podcast
which you've been doing when did you I
mean you started before me like it's
been over 10 years I mean everybody's
got a podcast now but it's rare that I
meet someone who's been doing it longer
than I have and I think you 2011 or
something like that when did you start
yeah that sounds right it's been it's
been 12 13 years something like that
it's crazy when you invited me to do
yours it was like it was at that comic
book store yeah is that there that's not
there anymore is it I think it's gone
right no it is that was a we didn't know
but there was a golden time yeah I was
being you know I wouldn't say I was
being taken advantage of but like I was
with a network that was taking the we
nobody had figured out how to turn it
into a job quite yet right I certainly
hadn't it was just forever before me too
we did it for years and years and years
and making no money if I got a little
check I'd be like oh my God and now I
look back and I'm like what what the
[__] was that like that's ridiculous but
anyway now we're sort of in this
opposite
time you know everyone knows this but
like we're now competing with Conan and
and I think all five talk show hosts
they're doing a mega podcast thing right
now like when does it end guys like when
like how you have to there's this great
uh New Yorker cartoon that I love by Leo
Cullum the late Leo Cullum and it's dogs
in a boardroom and they're wearing suits
and there's a a chart of growth and the
dog is saying um it's not enough that
dogs win cats must also lose and I just
think about this like insatiability
where it's like if there's money to be
made [__] go everybody go and I know
I'm over here ping out my thing and I've
enjoyed my coziness and now I'm like you
type in comedy podcast it's it's hard
like one of the reasons I keep doing it
one I love it I absolutely love it but
I'm also like I can't throw away a
following because now if you start a
podcast it's really hard to get oh it
would be so difficult to start now
impossible and and you can't
underestimate the impact of podcasting
on Comedy in general like every comedian
now has domain and control over their
work and connecting with an audience in
a way that they never did previously and
it's launched careers it's been very
good to you and and to a lot of people
and comedians were the first movers yeah
in the early early days even before you
started yeah Marin it was yeah it was
Marin it was Kevin Smith is actually the
OG right like Corolla those guys yeah
like all the uh uh who um Doug Doug
Loves Movies remember that show Y is he
still doing that I mean those it's the
comedians who were first yeah and you're
absolutely right right that the taste
changed it's like changing the diet of
an ecosystem right like once the
comedians started getting more
comfortable sharing all of their
feelings and thoughts and and kind of
getting more personal which was a big
part of the phenomenon then the audience
that came to see me for example would
know all this stuff about they already
they know you and they know what they're
getting involved in which because they
want to see you not oh it's a comedian
let's see what he's got and they want to
know the real you so sort of off the
table I remember I don't know what he
ended up doing but there was a comedian
who came out I I we don't need to say
who it was but he was like a little bit
older than me and he was like but when
I'm on stage I'm still going to talk
about having a girlfriend and kind of be
like you know what I mean I was like oh
I don't think that flies anymore no like
and that's wonderful for someone like me
like I want to share and be known and
now when I go out to audiences the
whole thing is like if you knew me we
could get deeper faster funnier and if
you already listen to the podcast it's
like you already know my perspective
let's just let's dive in and get into it
fast yeah but that that idea was born
out of the alternative comedy movement
wasn't it the storytelling yeah um
vulnerability Le kind of I wasn't doing
that thing I mean Marin that's what
Marin does also in a different way Mar
doesn't on stage and on his podcast but
I learned how to be
vulnerable um sort of by doing a podcast
the first time I was like you know
giving grief to my family or or talking
about my divorce like I I had no bits
about being divorced so like doing the
podcast the first time I talked about it
you really this is going to sound it's
like Chicken Little you think the sky is
going to fall you're like and my wife
left me she actually had an affair like
you just put a little toe in the water
and when that episode would drop I'd
have anxiety I'm like well I don't even
know what the fantasy was but let's say
she's going to hear it or somebody in my
family is going to hear someone in her
family is going to hear it none of these
things happen and then the next week you
go like it was a small Italian man named
Rocco or whatever it is used to make
that joke all the time and next thing
you know you're just in the water up
over your head of like sharing and
sharing and that informs your art and
then look what happened I did a TV show
that hinges on me being honest about my
divorce but it was podcasting that
taught me how to be soft enough and open
enough to to get to that place
artistically if I had just been doing
standup it would still be what's the
employee discount at the dollar store
podcasting was like yeast in the dough
yeah you can't you can't extract the two
from each other and how they've informed
each other and that's why I won't walk
away but what what do you think about
the whole world of podcasting now
because it is so different than when you
started well I don't want to be a a
grump but I do think some celebrity
doesn't necessarily mean
better well we learned that with all the
Spotify missteps and overspending just
because you're a name doesn't mean that
you're going to want to host a podcast
that's going to work that's right and
also I think a lot of people realize how
much work it is and yeah no get knee
deep into it and realize and if they're
not getting huge audience share right
out of the gate they'll just pull the
plug because they have many other things
that they could do but that's it's I
feel that way it probably sounded like I
meant me but I also just mean the guests
as well like so many of my favorite
episodes are people that you haven't
heard of and the the true weirdos it's
called you made it weird so we call the
fans weirdos the true weirdos listen to
all of them and they report the same
it's like some like I always talk about
like Pete Davidson did the podcast when
he was just a club comic that I thought
was incredible so like list don't skip
like um Malik Malik alisol just did it
today and I'm like I know there's a lot
of people that won't listen to the Malik
alisol episode I'm like you [__]
idiot see you in five years when he's
huge but like he's funny and interesting
today you know what I mean so like let
let's be more
interesting than Instagram let's be more
interesting than the Tabloid it's also
more gratifying as the host when you can
find some like gem in the rough and like
host them have an incredible experience
and then go like this to the world well
that is what I meant
days in the comic B you get ads involved
and I'm grateful for that through the
pic through both the strikes that are
happening right now podcasting is our
our livelihood it's like most of it
mentoring but it's like so I'm grateful
for the ads so I'm not saying this with
any malice but once you're promising a
number to an Advertiser it gets less
cute if I just want to have the author
of some book I really enjoyed on you
know what I mean so that does compromise
it
a little bit and going back to the meat
thing you're just sort of like it's just
what it is it's it's not great but I
can't really
have uh everybody on necessarily that I
want that's a shame you should be able
to do that you need like you need an
iron curtain between the advertising and
the editorial like you can't let
advertising inform which guest you're
going Malik did the show today so we're
still having the people on but I can't
like I couldn't have him on again next
week like there's who are listening to
you are listening they're listening for
the guest but they're listening because
they love you and they trust you and
you're a curator of taste so if you say
this is a person worthy of your
attention your audience is going to
follow you whether it's I know that's
true the maybe you have you know John
melen on you know it's going to get more
people are probably going to listen to
that but the drop isn't as precipitous
as you might think I would suspect like
when you have an unknown on because they
know that you've thought through this I
like you yeah I like you Chris Evans did
it Captain America which was which was
dope yeah oh that's cool he hasn't done
a lot of PODS I wonder if he do yours I
mean he's he's like a fit fella not that
you only I'd love to have him on yeah
it's fun to have fancy people on but
sometimes they're a lot harder to
interview because they're so media Savvy
they do so many interviews and you have
to find a different way in uh in my
experience that's the old Marin trick I
learned it from Marin you have to tell
them a story of sh you have to lead with
with vulnerability yeah you like oh I
remember I just [__] blood 20 minutes
ago and then they're like oh and then
what who are you exact you have to it's
it's the oldest podcast I don't want to
say it's a trick it's a trick in the
sense that it's a trick towards deep
rich in this moment [__] the show just
two human beings con me you can't expect
somebody to be honest and open if you're
not willing to do that yourself so it's
not a trick it's just we're setting the
stage this is is where I'm coming from
when people do it to me I love it if
you're TR I've said this before but like
podcasts are just an
excuse like this for you and me to sit
on a porch and have a SAS Barilla you
know what I mean and like so the more
things change the more they stay the
same it seems like oh this is so fancy
and we're in a black void uh but time
was black void Timeless black void but
we're really just doing what people have
always done we're on a wagon ride across
the dtas and we finally get to talk and
there used to be more time for that but
it's a human need if I were to drive up
to ohigh yeah this is the conversation
that I would have with you but because
our lives are the way that they are
that's an unlikely occurrence so I have
to create all this artifice yes in order
to have this cover but honestly dude if
you came to ohigh I wouldn't be talking
in this no of course
not and if you did Even though this is
you know what we should do we should
actually do that and just imagine that
there's microphones on and have a very
animated heightened version of listen to
this that we would have my wife and I
are very very happy uh it's just a a
wonderful gift of a relationship and
every Friday we do a bonus episode
called we made it weird it's on the same
feed but the we made it weird episodes
are Val and I and if that's not a
relationship hack meaning yeah that's
the joke with my wife all the time
what's that that cuz she comes on not
with that level of regularity but pretty
frequently and it's like oh okay we're
gonna talk now that's what I'm saying
yeah my even when Leela was a newborn we
always took at least an hour sometimes
two hours to have like the the F talk
about the treadmill and the fiery pit of
standup like the stakes let's put some
staks in it let's let's get best Pete
not bad date [__] dumbass Pete let's
get like people are going to hear this
and it's sort of like my father making
fun of my body even though that's not
what he meant motivating me to start
fasting or whatever it is let's put a
little pressure on this saying people
are going to hear it not not just for
the show but for the conversation itself
for what it gives us and this is true
every single we made it weird whe
without exception starts in a certain
way and I'm usually having some sort of
problem that we're
by the end I always feel always feel
better and it's like we could do this
but we don't so let's hack the system
let's turn it into part of our job and
force ourselves to talk and it's always
the episodes that we didn't want to do
we I was like maybe we can skip this
week whatever we forced ourselves to do
it those are always these incredible we
didn't even know what we were going to
talk about and we find something like
real cuz we got out of our own way yeah
yeah I'm I'm sitting here wondering
whether this is this is something that
that anybody could do right whether or
not they publish it but to create that
kind of formality with your partner to
sit down yeah and structure a
conversation where this is going to be
we may not share it publicly but it will
be recorded and we will have this for
posterity well talk this might be dark
but I think about like me and a nursing
home it's like fire up the we made it
weirds I want to listen to me and I'd
like to listen to me and Val 3 years ago
during the pandemic you know what I mean
when Leela was a newborn like these are
Treasures so yeah you know when you have
a sleepover there's a tape recorder you
hit record and you just kind of [__]
around those are Treasures like it's a
wonderful thing to be able to do cool so
I think if I were a relationship
therapist I would say once a week do a
pretend podcast don't even release it
just record
[Music]
it in this age of ultimate distraction
endless scrolling you have this standup
life you're a writer you wrote on
crashing co-created that show with Jud
you're in the sitcoms now you're doing
all kinds of you wrote you wrote you
wrote your book that came out and now um
you've got another special coming out
but all of that aside and this is back
to my original question around the kind
of uniqueness of your career path you're
also in this nebulous kind of new
interesting world of comedian writer
slash like thought leader sort of in
this spiritual space like I think of
rain Wilson like this with his new book
Soul boom I love rain he just came back
on the show he's great uh or and and and
our mutual friend Rob Bell or you know
Elizabeth
Gilbert um you do these shows at Largo I
think the last time I saw you actually
was at Largo that was like that anuka
Harris Consciousness yeah nights so you
do like all these these things that that
don't really fit into the typical kind
of standup yeah Persona yeah that are
truly unique to you yeah and those are
that's the most
rewarding interesting fertile part of my
life yeah you did you've done like like
these little these videos that you I
don't know how long the big think videos
and I was like you're like a Ted fellow
you know like you get you get on camera
and you're just like imparting wisdom
yeah well a lot of that thank you for
first of all I'm I'm just so touched
honestly that you just know everything
it's so cool uh well researched in
everything you are and that you care
it's cool it's really
cool um but yeah it took like some
getting I was just thinking about this I
had a joke where I I just wanted to say
I love Jesus it's just his fans that I'm
not crazy about or whatever right and I
remember I'm in Union Hall in Brooklyn
probably like 26 probably still married
first time
and you know it's a hip show Eugene
Merman probably Hannibal burus and I I
tried to say I like couldn't even look
at the crowd I was like I love Jes I
couldn't say I love Jesus to these
hipsters even though looking back who
[__] cares you know what I mean like
but I'm thinking again that the sky is
going to fall if I start telling these
people that I'm spiritually curious when
now my perspective as a 44-year-old is
I'm like Pete 99% of that room was was
raised in some tradition and would love
to not only hear you talk about it but
would also probably privately love to
hear you save some part of it for them
right because they're all walking around
Brooklyn sphincters you know tight
that's right uh feeling like they can't
be honest about what they're conflicted
about or the way they were brought up
saving bab from the bathroom BR voice to
that yeah exactly but so again just like
with the podcasting it it started slowly
it's just like can I talk about this is
is this okay and finding people that
were more far out like ramas who comes
from more of a Hindu tradition that was
sort of my way back in the mix okay we
have a different Avatar it's it's
haniman you know and and very similar to
Jesus and and then slowly finding
Richard Roar uh The Franciscan who's
like my spiritual father started kind of
making me com and Rob of course Rob Bell
making me more comfortable using
Christian language again just purely for
a psychological benefit it's so nice to
go back into the marred woods that you
escaped and go like was there anything
was there anything in here I want to
look at it fresh now for me no one's
telling me is there anything here and
finding and carving that way out had a
lot to do with being friends with Rob
seeing somebody who could we did a tour
together where we spoke together on
stage and yeah his his new book just
came out out where did you park your
SPAC yeah it's great yeah you guys did
like a Largo thing recently yeah we did
yeah so you know Rob is one of those
people that modeling is just so
important he modeled to me moving to
ohigh had something to do with him too
not we moved and then he moved but like
he used to live in lagona lagona beach
and I went down there and I was like
what yeah that doesn't make sense yeah
but I was also just kind of like there's
that but it's also like beautiful and I
was like I didn't know you could even
try to live in a beautiful place you
know and he did and I didn't know you
could talk about God in an honest way
where you're kind of like yeah I don't I
don't know what's going on but like what
what about this what does this resonate
does this resonate or I don't have a
masters of divinity but I'm welcome to
the conversation because I'm stuck in
the same predicament you are you know
those green lights you start having them
modeled to you and then the more you
learn like it comes out in my standup as
well bits of about the meaning of life
and I don't know why more
comedians are stepping away from the
exclusively jaded like get real like
stance and getting a little bit more
thoughtful a little bit more curious
about it because it's the most
interesting topic because cynicism and
irony works and it has worked for a long
time so it's reliable yeah it's
riskier yeah to well you know the the
god bid in the special did you get that
for yeah yeah I'm just
to write a joke about God in the
special uh that that people enjoy that I
felt comfortable doing at the Irvine
Improv or the [__]
wherever those those are always the
moments for me where my my hair kind of
stands up on the back of my neck and I'm
I'm dropped into the present and we're
actually connecting about like what's
going on here instead of just kind of
being like taking life as a foregone
conclusion yeah
yeah back to that idea of the absurdity
of it all um the afterlife versus The
Miracle of Life now and realizing that
uh you know it's all [__] insane
right yeah um I think is really this
like at the very heart of like what's
best about what you have to offer like
reminding us yeah of the
lunacy that we're spin spinning on this
rock you know
vast Darkness the core of it is most of
the time when I'm talking about this
stuff is I'm trying to get us all in the
same boat you know I I don't care if you
call it God or nothing we're talking
about a mystery is something erupted
into the universe and you know I want
you to stress less yeah and and just
notice what's going on and and sort of
surrender to the unknowing like the the
big think thing that I did I think it's
pemma childrenin said you're the sky the
rest is just
weather and that's not just like a cute
little magnet for your fridge that's
when you're overwhelmed and like shaking
with anger or crippled in grief like
that's the type of thought that you can
step back allow what's happening to
happen but it's not just a thought
experiment it's it's like trying to get
in touch with the part of you that's
witnessing it you know and that that to
me is what spirituality is everything
that I am keeps changing but
spirituality is interested in what
doesn't change what what what is
constant yeah I mean it's also this
permission that you give or this
encouragement for us to nurture that
that part of us that that needs to and
wants to engage with awe and wonder
right you also said in one of the big
thing pieces uh you were talking about
um Joseph Campbell and you were talking
about uh religious literalism and you
said that uh like something like literal
literal truth is the lowest form of
truth right and I think that's yeah it's
such a beautiful statement but talk a
little bit more about what you meant by
that well it's funny I tell my daughter
stories I haven't said this before but
I've been telling her stories and and my
daughter uh always wants to know if
they're real like I I told her a story
about going in the ocean and a you know
iridescent fish gave me a necklace with
a shell on it so I could breathe
underwater so I could find the treasure
and I was with my brother and then I
hurt myself so we had to dropped the
treasure so he could take me to the
shore and then the fish came back and
gave my brother the treasure even though
we had lost it so it's a pretty basic
morality tail
um or you know you could look at it a
lot of different ways but at the end the
next day she's like Disney hire this man
she goes I want one of those necklaces
and boy if she's not disappointed when
I'm like that's made that was a story
and she she's mad so we've started
already trying to Prime her to this idea
that there are some truths so big they
can only be told with lies uh that
that's a cute way of saying metaphor is
the only language we have to speak of
God um and I say this in the special
it's Richard Roar as well metaphor means
always true sometimes really happen
because what's interesting about the
Bible one of the weird things about that
text is that it's metaphor overlay with
history you know what I mean it's like
metaphorized history and we don't know
where the line is uh you know opinions
vary but when you're trying to and if
you've taken psychedelics and that was a
huge part of my appreciation of metaphor
but when you're trying to talk about the
ineffable metaphor isn't just as close
as you can get it's the only way to do
it it it it stirs you and moves you and
in a way way that it's the truth of it
is it's true in the way that energy
moves in the world it's it's true in the
way the patterns of the universe are
reflected in the story because you can
tell a story and it's [__] like you
know but the the metaphors and the myths
that stick with us they'll they'll rock
you I just listen to one called the toe
bone and the tooth it's about this guy
they're all about a guy under under like
sort of underprivileged guy in a village
goes into the woods falls in love with a
goddess his father doesn't want them to
get married he has to go through these
it's very Genesis he has to go through
these trials then he has to bring her
back to the Village he forgets that
she's in the woods she she dies she
decomposes then he has to go back and
all he can find of her is a toe bone and
a tooth that is not if you're interested
in that story you should look it up but
like we know that we go like oh my God
we know the Beloved is is the Eternal
and we TR and we tried our best to
remember but we left her in the woods
and all we have are these remnants and
you hear it and you your Skin's lit on
fire and and we're [__] stuck with
numbers and measurements and recipes
like get the [__] out of here none of
that [__] helps you when your heart is
broken none of them none of that helps
when your grandfather is dying or or
when a baby is born like poetry is
similar it it we get that [__] out of
here until your wife leaves you then
William Blake gets a lot more important
but we've become
interested in or or fascinated or
obsessed with the quantifiable and the
reproducible and the and the and the
material and it's like okay but you know
we're leaving a
lot in our rear view that That's
essential yeah you know it's so
emasculated in our culture well because
you can't have sex with it and you can't
sell it really you know what I mean so
like what are you doing I'll tell you
what you're doing is you're feeling more
at home in the universe this is my whole
thing the fact that it's like cowardly
to go to therapy like like the people
where I'm from if you say you're in
therapy they're it's
like I'm like is there anything more
cowardly than not facing your demons
like who's the coward I I might just be
sitting on a couch but I'm going into
the cave where the Vader mask cuts open
and it's my face like that's the hero
and and it's easy to do the same with
spirituality be like it's a bunch of
Lies yeah Santa Claus isn't real great
but what is the story of Santa Claus
what is the point what is done in secret
is rewarded or whatever it might be I
don't know man
literalism is a [__] terrible body to
snuggle up to in your bed at night and
and the warm bosom of myth has kept
human beings alive and by the way don't
don't get me started every video game
every movie it's all right there sure
every avenger get the [__] out of here
and and Joseph Campbell is like the
gateway drug yeah for a lot of people
especially in this town that's right
well he changed my life he said God is
is a metaphor for a mystery that
absolutely transcends all categories of
human thought including being and
non-being so I that I could get on board
with that's a God I I feel like that's a
god anyone could agree on it's a
metaphor meaning God is Not an old man
in the sky an old man in the sky is a
metaphor for a metaphor God itself is a
metaphor and a metaphor for that
metaphor is an old man in the sky old
he's older than you he's been around in
the sky has a higher perspective than
you on a throne he's powerful share
these just ways of understanding a force
right but that's a metaphor for God
which is itself a metaphor for a mystery
something unknown is doing something we
know not what right that we so this is
also in my special Barry Taylor the road
manager for ACDC says God is the name
name of the blanket we put over the
mystery to give it a shape God is in the
mystery to give it a
shape and I say shouldn't we have
learned this in church why am I learning
this from the road manager for ACDC and
it's not about solving the mystery it's
about appreciating the fact that it is a
mystery and we want to talk about it and
more than that we want to commune with
it and to know that we have to give it
some sort of symbol Carl Young says
we're not transformed by ideas we're
transformed by symbols this is why the
Cru ified Christ is still a hot thing
stories yes we know this this is why I'm
telling my daughter about the the
treasure in the iridescent fish so when
somebody says to you as I'm sure they
probably do often like Pete explain to
me your your notion of spirituality or
how do you define your relationship with
the Divine like how do you answer that
question well in this context I would
say mystical whatever mystical
Christianity mystical spirituality
mystical is just a fancy way of saying
experiential so a lot of these things
had to do with psychedelics that really
open the box for me but I'm happy to say
that there's spirituality Beyond
psychedelics that's still part of my
life but there are a lot of
non-chemically induced moments of
transcendence that come from quiet that
come from Solitude that come from
contemplation whatever it might they and
for me as a heady person comes from
reading or listening to talks or
whatever it can drop anchor into the
moment listening to echarle if anyone
listening if you don't want any
religious language but you want to know
what I'm talking about the Power of Now
read by eart the book just listen to
that I listen to it two three times a
year it's incredible and when you're
listening to it you'll feel your skin
you'll feel the air resting on your skin
you'll
feel reality rert spy is another one go
go on YouTube and type in Rupert Spyro
it's all free that dude will make you
feel like you're on mushrooms and you
don't have to go to the park and meet a
guy named skis except you did right
which is curious because you're already
so spiritually inclined so spiritually
curious so what was it about doing
psychedelics that unlocked something or
or opened up a you know a new portal for
you well I
wasn't there the time that I took
mushrooms at
bonaroo um somebody told it's in my book
but um Reggie Watts and Amy Schumer and
these Comics were like we had a day off
and they were like you should Kurt roner
they were like let's we should buy some
mushrooms and do them cuz we're bonaroo
and I think it was Amy said like it's
like weed it's like a strong weed and I
was like I took it I was like this is
not this is not a strong weed um but I'm
so glad that she said that didn't OV
explain it didn't oversell it but at
that time in my life I think I was
pretty much just not thinking about it
about spirituality too much I all my
friends were atheists I saw how
beautiful that could be they had
morality they they felt at home in the
world they weren't like debaucherous
evil people they were beautiful people
so I was like okay maybe I'm an atheist
I took mushrooms a pretty mild dose I
split a dose with my girlfriend at the
time but what it was was the
ineffability I couldn't talk about it so
I remember very profoundly I didn't have
like a Jesus experience or a god
experience I felt very happy very alive
and and and things were very Visual and
you know you have that like at Oneness
feeling with the universe which is so
silly to say that like it's no big deal
that's like the biggest deal in the
world you feel like at one with
everything and everything's breathing
and you're that thing and it's
incredible but the point is when I was
sort of
peing what was left of Pete went I'm
going to have to talk about this and
ruin it like I'm going to come back and
my girlfriend's is going to say how was
that and I'm going to say what I just
said breathing at one all this [__] n
like what is that it's not the
experience and then I was like oh my God
that's the whole thing the experience of
God however you come about it or the
story of Christ or the story of Buddha
or the story of Muhammad whatever it is
the words aren't it but there is a thing
and I everyone said this a million times
there the finger pointing to the Moon
that's as good as you can do and that's
those were my words trying to talk about
so I came back like a chimp being
like and that wasn't it and it's
laughable but that made me go that made
me get curious about what metaphor is if
we can't talk about it literally how can
we talk about it and then you get things
like Joseph kampbell I watched the the
power of myth on PBS like everybody
about the DVDs tore through it and I was
like oh you know remember an analogy is
the man ran like a deer a metaphor is
the man was a deer so it's not just a
metaphor isn't just like a comparison
it's it's it's it's big it's written in
big graffiti markers and it and and has
the power to kind of Transport you not
kind of to transport you to that place
and that one experience was
enough uh well that was a pretty mild
experience since then I've I I wouldn't
say I'm a huge psychedelic person uh for
my taste I've seen some people overdo it
that's just my personal judgment just
flat out that's just a judgment I'm over
here going like take it easy because
they are fun but they're not Escapist
experiences they're the opposite of
escapism they're confron
experiences um but I've done a lot of
different things uh uh and I'm very glad
that I've done a lot of different I've
done I did five Meo DMT which is oh wow
yeah which is the big one yeah but and
short short acting too right it's about
15 minutes but I mean what is 15 minutes
when time vanishes you know the first
thing I said when I came back I think
was how long how long was I gone cuz you
don't go Pete doesn't go I I'm the I'm
sort of unqualified to talk about it but
I had this very profound death and it's
what I wanted I everybody in my group
got what their intention was it was very
freaky did it in a structured group in a
very intent intentional and spiritual
with a guide who I absolutely love and
stayed in touch with but like mine was I
want to hang out with myself capital S
self like I want
to just be my pure being not Pete
not my story I don't want to talk about
my family I don't want to talk about
anything I just want to be reduced into
being into isness and that's exactly
what happened and it
was absolutely incredible the best I can
do to describe it it's not visual but
like but it also sort of is it doesn't
make any sense it felt like and this is
good news that I can share with you even
if you never do it you don't go anywhere
you when you and I'll even be so bold as
to say when you die you don't go
anywhere in fact you can't go anywhere
the whole
thing is here so instead of shooting off
into space it's actually more like
everything that isn't just you goes away
and your left at home would be how I put
it in the most familiar and safe place
and everything else Falls away and you
go Heaven is a decent metaphor what is
heaven the clouds and all your family is
there um
sure everything is there and nothing is
there but explain that to a child you
die you go to a place where you know
there's Grandma and Grandpa sure also
everything alive is there everything
that died is there everything that will
be alive is there and you just go I'm
hung home I I felt like a
lobster and and the meat was taken out
in one piece and it left behind the
shell and since that day like lobsters
I've never gotten a tattoo but if I did
I'd get a lobster right here because it
was this profound like this is
not I am not a body I am free I am still
as God created me sort of thing wow and
it was [__] dope but it was
experiential cuz if you said this to me
I'd be like yeah I mean you're pointing
at the Moon right now I've never had any
of these experiences and by the way I
don't recommend them this isn't I'm not
saying this for legal reason I'm not
saying I'm going to either like I have
lots of reasons why you know um I
probably shouldn't or maybe I should I
don't know like I reserve judgment on
that but I will say I'm certainly not
recommending it please understand I'm
you know I'm not advising anybody to do
this but the point I'm trying to make is
the point that you're making earlier
which is the only way like as somebody
who hasn't had these experiences hearing
you try to describe it and me trying to
understand what you're saying is barely
I assume scratching the surface of what
you're actually trying to communicate
with me because words are not an
adequate vehicle for doing that and you
could say like a very and that's where
metaphor and myth and all of that better
ways of trying to get somebody to
understand what you're what you're
trying to say right the lobster thing
came like 4 days after you the shell or
you're the lobster taken out of the sh
I'm the meat leaving the shell behind
the tattoo should actually be the the
meat I don't know what the lobster looks
like when you take the shell away my
favorite that would be a unique tattoo
to get if you ever want to get me a gift
give me a little lobster cuz I love
remembering it interesting I I again
look this stuff seems to be part and I'm
an addict too I I don't drink anymore
and so I I'm a I can't say no two
addicts are the same this fits in with
me the one that I did most recently that
was the most Lucid cuz as I'm explaining
this to you from a very rational place
if I can't remember it or describe it
really uh what's the point right so you
you're sort of left with this
[Music]
like you know yeah and I'm trying to
hold on to it so from a very rational
point of view then why do it then I did
ketamine um again in a spiritual setting
with a guide and it
was incredibly Lucid I I found that to
be much more hold on to a bull so you
don't leave the planet you're in your
body but you had this very visceral
whenever I do a psychedelic or anything
spiritual happens to me I always think
of my mother and I I love my Mom very
much and I go I want to give this to my
I I got to show my mom this but the
beautiful thing was the k was like or
the experience
was there's so much less to do than you
think and that was the good news that I
had meaning I don't even have to tell
you to do it or even infect you with the
idea meaning like it's all not only will
it be okay it's already okay because the
it that is okay is outside of this
timeline and that's actually if this
makes any sense where we are right now
and in a Quantum sense there is no past
or future that's kind of what I'm saying
right like it's our relationship with
time that causes our suffering yeah and
when you're done with it you can drop it
and that thing I just I I remember tears
were streaming down my face and and this
is very non-u but you know hopefully
people enjoyed I was like I got to tell
my mom about this and it was
like you're doing
this like it's all one thing and you're
doing it for
everyone like
there is no Pete that did it and my mom
who didn't it's one thing arcing towards
knowing itself and when it knows itself
the whole thing wakes up it's it's it's
a booby trap a loving booby trap
conversations like this between us lead
you synchronicities going all the way
and when you when when you're
ready it wakes up the whole thing wakes
up not the Buddha wakes up the Christ W
this whole thing wakes up just like you
woke up from your dream and everybody
was gone
and it's okay none of the mind it's okay
that's the end of the world I'm I'm
operating at like 10% of understanding
what you just said it's okay just listen
to it again on half speed and uh maybe
do some K I'm just kidding don't do K me
yeah you your podcast is called uh you
made it weird I think you're making it
weird I am making it weird in a good way
no I know this is this is it dude I'm
hearing myself too and I'm like it is
laughable but if I told you a
story like my brother dropping the
treasure and the fish bringing the
treasure what is the point of that story
it's like in the end it's okay you know
it's like it's the Prodigal Son all you
need in my opinion is the Garden of Eden
for our beginning and then the prodical
sun and the story of the prodical son
everyone knows but it's it's worth
repeating you're the son you got your
inheritance life this is our inheritance
we did the beautiful thing it's very
similar to the Garden of Eden we left we
ate the apple we left that's okay
remember the father's not mad that the
sun left all that guilt and fear and
shame and God oh get off my lawn [__]
[__] ego [__] you left you were
free to leave you went into the world it
does say I believe you squandered your
inheritance which is what we're doing
we're just squandering we're eating
nachos and whatever the [__] we're doing
it's okay we ran out of money we ended
up working with the pigs as good Jewish
boys in the story terrible it's like the
lowest of the low and then we remembered
that's key we remembered wait my father
is a
king I can go home it wasn't bad boy
runs away it was boy runs away to play
to dance to spend his inheritance it's
his inheritance go do it then when
things got rough I remember maybe my
father will make me a servant in his in
his kingdom goes home home God's not mad
dad's not mad Slaughters the fatten calf
gives him new sandals anoints him in oil
gives him new robes celebrates that he
came home that's the whole [__] thing
right and that was Jesus's closer you
know what I mean that was his big finish
to the sermon on the it's the big one
that's all you need I I I I'm very firm
on that [__] my ketamine story and my
five Meo story who cares the whole thing
is your father loves you you can go
home and that
remembrance is often triggered by those
painful episodes in our life right th
that is the that is the conduit to find
your way back home full circle you don't
go home until you're with the pigs
echarle woke up when he said I can't
live with myself any longer he was going
to kill himself he went there's an eye
and a self what is this I can't live
with myself any longer Who's Who and he
dropped the the ego and he got into his
s capital S self that's all you really
need the other one that I love Amma the
hugging Saint told this story when I saw
her in New York she's incredible there
was a doctor I've been hugged by her
isn't that great we named our dog Amma
beautiful I really had like hug I had a
real moment when I hugged her it was
great maybe she told the story when you
saw her no I don't think so there was a
doctor and he and he was dealing with
terminally ill people and he brought his
dog to
work and of course he couldn't bring the
dog into the exam room so he closed the
door and he was administering you know
help to this dying person and the dying
person was like worried about dying and
all the while the dog is scratching on
the
door and the dog she said can you
comfort me cuz I'm dying he said well I
think it's a little bit like my dog I've
never brought my dog to work my dog
doesn't know what's in this room it's
all unknown it's all frightening and
strange but she still wants to come in
cuz she knows her master is in here and
I was like that's it we don't know what
the [__] is going on here but whether or
not you trust it is key whether or not
you see it as your father going home
whether or not you see yourself as God's
child these are the Comforts of story
that in the midst of this madness and
this unknowingness if you can have a
core of like Richard Roy said the point
of life is to accept that you are
accepted it's written on my mirror in
chalk marker accept that you are
accepted and there's another line from A
Course in Miracles on my mirror that
says who could be disappointed who asks
for what he has already it's [__]
great yeah it's [__] great beautiful
but how do you like I'm I'm I'm thinking
of the person who's listening to this
who hasn't had their Reckoning yet they
haven't hit their pain moment and
they're trying to wrap their head around
what you mean by this notion of of
remembering or returning home like how
do you communicate to that person or how
do you get somebody to you know connect
with that possibility in their own
life that's why I'm not putting that
question off to but when people email me
you know on social or something and
they're like I can't it's Nails on a
chalkboard you say I'm God's child it's
Nails on a chalkboard or or Jesus or
Buddha or anything because of the the
baggage of that people are carrying
around from whatever experiences they
had yeah I relate to that I had that and
people like first of all Joseph Campbell
who's just going to say it's a story and
that's great but then at Carle who's all
just the sacrament of the present moment
and when you start
getting naked I was just talking about
this today on my own podcast I was like
why are Adam and Eve naked it's because
they're they don't they're not clothed
in the ego in the story just pure and
when you drop through practices through
reading that book whatever it might be
and you start getting familiar with who
are you like you're you're wearing a
space suit suit you know what I mean
right and we start thinking we're the
suit this is ramas rhas would say I go
hello rich and you go hello Pete you're
a comedian I go yes and we are Americans
I remember I was in Italy I saw a
ladybug and I was like this ladybug has
no idea to tell
him has no idea to to tell him how many
[__] things are we carrying around
and who are you when you drop them and
which of those things are
undroppable I don't I don't think there
are any that are undroppable and Raman
Mahari has this great thing where he
goes when you're stoking the fire of
your own awareness the last thing you
get the fire going the last thing you
throw in is the stick you were staking
the fire with you can even drop your
practice all of it can go because you're
zero your your smallest most irreducible
undividable
you that's that's the part that knows
this whether or not you Vibe with this
language but there's a part of you and I
would also recommend rert SP
if you if you uh read being aware of
being aware which is a very short book
and every chapter says the same thing
you can just read the first chapter I
know Richard Roar but I haven't I
haven't read that book rert is a
beautiful non-u teacher but he will just
go like what is it that's aware of your
experience and he's like that's nobody's
asking that he he says we're like the
screen of a
movie and every every body gets so
caught up in the content of the movie
just like we do when we watch a movie
that you forget you're looking at a
screen but you're the screen it's not
colored or changed in any meaningful way
by the Light that's on it right now I'm
so oh I'm on a podcast all this I'm a
screen what is the screen what what
distance is an illusion like this sound
is farther than this it's all happening
on the screen of my awareness and the
the the the additional delusion to that
is that it's all happening in our head
right but that is also just an
appearance in Consciousness that's what
I so science I I'm a pro science person
obvious I I hope I don't have to say
that but science will say I saw a TED
Talk where they're like reality is a
agreed upon uh group
hallucination and that's really right on
with a lot of mystical traditions this
is Maya or this is play or whatever you
want to say but they'll say it
originates in the brain so that's like
you and I are having a dream
and I hold up a a ring box and I go this
dream is coming from this box like why
would a part of the dream be a reliable
source of the dream what the [__] do we
know about the mind you know what I'm
saying so we're going it originates in
the amydala of the blah blah blah that's
also you can't remove the Observer it's
it's influencing and part of and
drenched in The observed you are the
observed right the idea that there is a
self right that is observing right is is
a further illusion right and that that
self resides somewhere inside your head
right and and that's hard like it takes
practice to disabuse yourself because
it's
so entrenched in our deep rooted
attachment to what is real and just in
the way that you learned it I watched my
daughter learn it pinching I feel that I
don't feel that you know what I mean
watched her learn it right and this idea
that you're sitting over there and I'm
over here yeah these things are just
appearances in Consciousness yeah that's
right so I don't mean to put the
question off but when people say I don't
know where to start the power of now
byak especially him reading it is a
really great place to start because
everybody without any practice can
listen to someone talking about the
quality of of the present moment and you
start to what happens you start to to
disappear so the things that are in the
way I am a person I am an American I am
a man I am a comedian all these stuff
when that goes away and you get really
quiet and yet you're still there that
beingness is a is a is a pointer to God
I always say that you know when Moses
met God in the Old Testament he said I
am that I am or I am I am and I always
thought God was being kind of cheeky
like he's like I am forget about it you
don't need to know who I am he's saying
I am when you consider this 5,000 years
ago I am
amness I am beingness and that's not
something you need to take from me you
can drop spelunk into yourself close
your eyes follow your breath and try to
experience what it feels like to just be
a like a little be the screen yeah and
then when you see that okay so here's
another one Muji m o o ji he has a
meditation called the invitation to
Freedom it's on iTunes I believe there's
two versions just get the cheaper one
cuz they're the same this dumb dumb
about both um but he goes uh he leads
you through this meditation where he
goes come in this room he's like but
before you come in leave your shoes
outside I'm not going to do it justice
and he goes also leave your mind outside
leave your past leave any fears of your
future leave your identity just come in
as zero and then when you do that and
you know there's music and there's
breathing it takes you through it he
goes like let's let's look at this let's
look at what you as zero is and he goes
is there a
boundary that you can find is there a
point where you hit where on the other
side of it it is
not and you just do it like don't take
my word for it just go like okay where
does this end this this infinite
spaciousness that I experience so much
it's a what the hell is water moment I
experience the Eternal in the infinite
so much that I don't even recognize it
anymore so get curious look for it what
does that practice look like for you on
a daily basis like how do you stay so
connected to
that honestly I love talking about it
with you I told you when I came in I was
having all these emails and losing my
mind getting stressed so there's always
a fresh
humbling it's like veganism it's like
you know this stuff and then you lose it
that's that's extra annoying you're like
it was easier when I didn't even know it
so there's always going to
be moments where you forget but I take
comfort in the fact that there are
people like eart like Muji like uh
rert like Christ like whoever take your
pick that in the same way that my
daughter learned I am separate these
people by wrote verily verily the word
of God finally reversed the flow of the
river and now they're like I don't think
that way anymore and then when they are
stressed or they're angry it might
happen but they don't identify with it
whereas I do right but what you're
saying is you have like a mindfulness
practice where you're bringing this into
your you're trying to like bring it into
your everyday experience and reminding
yourself throughout the day when you
yeah lose yourself in emails or whatever
because life is the way that it is right
it's like this this reflex
to it's the pain becomes the reminder
like like sobriety it's like I lose
myself I'm
shaking with anger or whatever it might
be that just happened my Dad upset me it
was over that thing that I told you
about that he made me feel bad about my
body um so we were talking about that I
got mad but you know a very practical
one is rain recognize allow investigate
and
nurture have you heard that probably at
some point it's the way this goes yeah
uh but when I'm really stuck in my S you
don't judge it it there's no nothing
gained in going like I thought I was a
spiritual person and I just call that
guy a piece of [__] or whatever I'm
meditating yeah exactly exactly
recognize oh I'm very angry except if I
feel this way the rest of my life it's
okay that's your brain has no idea what
to do with that your pain has no idea I
used to a big practice of Mantra of mine
is yes thank you something goes terrible
the flight is cancel whatever yes yes
thank you it has no idea what to do with
that it just when you remove the
resistance short circuits it yeah
because it's the resistance and the
attachment that creates the suffering
that's right and then you know I'm going
off what I was about to say but this is
more important Byron ktie is a huge
teacher of mine and the work and if you
read loving what is that's a that's a
lifechanging book and you can do
something called the work so uh you're
suffering because your flight is delayed
let's let's look at the beliefs um uh
this Airline doesn't care about me or
Airlines or I'm not safe unless this
Airline loves me you know you can look
unpack it flight should never be delayed
is that true no but people don't stop is
that true my dad should not say things
that unintentionally hurt my feelings he
does he did so why am I pushing up
against reality well it's also the idea
that we know what's in our best interest
or we know the difference between what
is good and bad for us let's do it so my
dad doesn't understand me is that true
do you know another person's interior
reality do you know what their intention
are or what they feel do you even know
what you feel like it's so much more
amorphous but we walk around going like
I've been slighted I've been attacked so
the work is huge I've been doing it
every morning since I had that little
what what is so it's you just walk
through the that process like what does
that look like my father doesn't
understand me let's take that one
um is it true is the first one and let's
say You're really angry you go yeah it's
true he doesn't understand me the second
one is uh can you be absolutely certain
that that's true I love it it just makes
me smile can you be absolutely certain
that your dad doesn't understand you and
you're like
no no you have to find a real no and
maybe even say yes you get to keep going
either way but usually I've been doing
it long enough that when I get the
thought out and the way you get to those
thoughts Journal like you're five years
old dad's G to kill me dad's gonna eat
me uh I'm not safe if my parents aren't
happy was one that I just did the next
one is um how do you feel when you
believe it my dad doesn't understand why
I feel alone I feel isolated I feel sad
I feel depressed I feel angry I feel
cold I feel
ashamed take your all of those are true
but you feel justified in that in that
emotion yeah and I there's an yeah
exactly self that's good I don't
normally do the positive ones but yeah
feel self-righteous like it is doing
something for you oh yeah yeah um it's
it's scapegoating as well and then the
next one is how would you feel if you
didn't believe the thought and you go if
I didn't believe that my dad doesn't
understand me I'd go I'd feel spacious
I'd feel free I'd feel happy I'd be
light I'd be clear I'd be whatever all
those words pretty much mean the same
and also maybe uncomfortable because you
no longer have a a handy antagonist yeah
humble and to channel your weird
emotions that's right yes then the next
step is you do the turnaround my dad
does understand understand me and you
come up with three examples of how
that's true and you go this guy raised
me he's been watching me
closely you know you go he knows this
this and this and this and this you
start getting you list those things and
and then you go I don't understand my
father how is that true well you know am
I I'm not really making that much effort
to understand him I'm really just kind
of painting him how how I see fit how I
get angry or whatever and then um so you
do the turnaround
and uh I think that's the last step it's
really really powerful when you start
writing down your suffering thoughts
that's the first step is actually the
most powerful when I when I told you I
did the work on I am not safe unless my
parents are happy or my father cannot
connect and engage you start getting
real and going like my father cannot
connect and engage in a way that I
understand connecting and engaging he's
never going to talk like you and I are
talking
you would you would prefer okay so then
my father needs to connect and engage
with me in a way that I prefer for me to
be safe get the [__] out of here there's
a holy laughter in going like where did
I get that well when you were a child
these people literally kept you alive
and you're still holding on to that and
you you go how is it not true well I've
been safe all this time that's a pretty
big evidence still alive I'm still alive
I'm fine there's two two people in
Boston in their 80s farting into a sofa
and I think they as if I could know
their emotional state and I think that
emotional state hinges on my physical
safety you wouldn't believe what you
believe you wouldn't believe what you
believe and what you believe you'll take
it because the zero of nobody is is so
uncomfortable that you'd rather be angry
than
happy the zero of nobody wait explain
that I just mean if I drop my anger and
I'm just saying and loving what is
loving and accepting what is I start to
get a little shaky I don't think I exist
so you ever catch yourself loving that
you're late to the airport cuz you're
[__] real godamn it I have a show
tonight in St
Louis what the [__] you you're so alive
you're the center of the universe and
and if you're like a little hermit and
you go flights are delayed you know you
start to vanish and the ego gets shaky
and it would rather you pick a fight
yeah or it's going to grab on to
something that that asserts that it
exists in the world and those tend to be
those trusty opinions that we assemble
to construct what we believe is our
identity because you don't remember that
your father is the king and they I know
that sounds that sounded so Christian it
made my deck go inside my body but it's
like you don't remember that being is
safe it's trustworthy that this this
idea that something made you to judge
you to then torture
you is is that's the ego's thought
system that that's that's this weird
separate scared killer be killed thing
that we've found oursel in that's not
Ultimate Reality and the more you taste
that the more you trust it the more you
go okay the flight's delayed what trips
you up the most these days my parents
it's still yeah isn't that [__] up
when does it end I know like you moved
out how old were you I was 22 21 yeah I
mean I I wasn't living at home but I
mean I left Boston when I was 22 so that
was
another parents and then they're sort of
made gelatinous by Boston right like
there's more power there yeah yeah um so
I get that yeah it's crazy [__] 57
yeah I'm a little sad to hear that
you're still you know i' come a long way
Pete yeah there's still work there that
needs to get done you know what I mean
and Buddy in this conversation in this
womb like abys I I feel safe being like
and that's okay but when I'm mad at my
folks
it's it's it takes over completely mhm
you know I'm doing a joke about it
that's how I process it I go every time
I've wanted my father to apologize to me
for hurting my feelings I end up
apologizing to him for having hurt
feelings that's how it's it's I've never
gotten like a um oh really oh I'm sorry
gez yeah and you and you never will
right and you're the one who suffers and
I suffer and the path to Freedom is
forgiveness and forg forgiveness comes
in the form of that type of contrary
action but okay so the I have a lot to
say about forgiveness but like so of
course in Miracles it's it's a little
Advanced I wouldn't ask anybody to start
on a course of Miracles but if you've
been on the spiritual path a long time
you might want to check it out but
there's a great line it's like a Jailer
is not free he's bound with his prisoner
that image is just so powerful to me I'm
keeping my parents in jail like being
righteously mad at them but I'm the
[__] idiot jail keeper that has to
live in the prison with them like I'm
suffering so forgiveness and
intellectual forgiveness sort of isn't
really great Mercy Divine Mercy comes
from not an
intellectual oh they did the best they
could and consider where they were
coming from and I can let that go it all
worked out all that [__] is nothing
father Greg Bole who's another huge
teacher of mine friend he's a beautiful
man he said forgiveness is overrated
Mercy is is where it's at and mercy
comes from me recognizing that you and I
are actually the same thing and when you
can experience
that really deep down then you can can
actually forgive because you recognize
it's kind of it's really just our dream
and you're just kind of here so I can
learn who I am and if I want to know
that God loves me I have to practice by
loving you it's not just to be a good
person I give you the Forgiveness that I
want I want salvation so I give it to
you that's kind of the the whole thing
and draw that distinction between that
action and this notion of Mercy like
Mercy being uh a disabusing oneself of
The Duality right is that that's the
differentiation yeah and and the
practice of that when you feel impulsed
by your father to carry on the example
well I can't do it in real time I have
to do it slowly but that stickiness that
static of trying to unpack it and work
with it is the difficult wrestle to get
me to a place place where I'm like oh I
forgot again I forgot again and the
Forgiveness comes is more of the
intellectual exercise and and can useful
too in fact with my parents I don't know
if Mercy can be hard to come by it can
take three three four five six seven
eight weeks to get to Mercy forgiveness
here's here's a great tip tip this is
what I do when I'm trying to forgive
somebody even if it's your mercy hack
this is my forgiveness I don't know if
it's quite Mercy but I I go if I if I
were them I'd be them and that sounds
like the most basic thing in the world
but if so my dad or let's pick somebody
on the highway somebody cuts me off and
they're bumper stickers covered in all
sorts of politics I don't agree with and
I'm mad at them and that works in real
time you go if I were them I'd be them
meaning if you had grown up the way they
grew up had all of the life experiences
that they had were raised by the parents
that that person had Etc ad nause had
the morning they were having ex you
would make every decision exactly the
way that they have we are so much less
fixed than we think we are meaning if I
move
to I I I never want to say a specific
say because I don't want to say it's
Backwoods or something but if I move to
like a rural Southern
place would I shift like would I start
to kind of maybe I'd buy a shotgun
because there's Bears or something yeah
probably something like that maybe I
don't know just in the same way that a
lot of people that are from certain
rural areas move to Manhattan they get a
little they get a lot more gay friendly
they tend to be when there's 150,000 gay
people and some of them are your friends
your politics start to change so who are
we what's going on let's go easy on
yourself like you're changing all the
time right the ego hates that though the
ego wants to believe everything is
static and is very attached to this
identity yeah that it has crafted right
and doesn't want you understanding the
ucer nature of that that's right it's
very threatened by that and even things
like I'm not a murderer and then you put
me in a post-apocalyptic situation where
a guy's coming at me with a baseball bat
with knives in it suddenly I'm a
murderer you know what I mean like what
is it what's going on like you can take
yourself less seriously but going back
to the if I were them i' would be them
that does help in real time I wish my
mom would understand this this or this
well if I
was born in that family in Lithuania and
left when I was seven fleeing World War
II and went to School in South Boston
all that stuff if I were them I'd be
them and you don't even have to know
them [__] Trump oh God what an idiot
if I was him I'd be him you know how I
know cuz he's
him he's him and if I were in that I'd
be doing the exact same
thing because I'd be him yeah all the
all the good ones are so obvious that
they it's like carrying a wet stone from
the ocean it dries up by the time you
get to the beach but it's frustrating
it's annoying that that's the way that
it is I know you want to go behind the
Velvet Rope yeah and just go I get it
now it's that that's the answer again
it's the same answer yeah well believe
me man you go on these psychedelic
things meditation things and you always
end up at the same thing like the
prodical son the punch line of the
prodical son the father says you're
always with me and everything I have is
yours that's the punchline mhm and
that's always the punchline and yet our
shame gets kicked in the fact that we
poop three times a day or whatever it is
the fact that we we're horny and we're
mad and we go there's no way Dad's going
to accept me back over and over and over
and over and that's that's just how it
goes it's a it's a wave it's up and down
and up and down yeah well I think that's
a good place to land the plane it's up
and down and it's up and down up and
down baby um beautiful man uh wow that
was amazing I really appreciate really
cool came in at the beginning and you
all like email and you you know I was
like is this going to be okay and then
you you warmed up to it I shouldn't have
read emails I hate emails no it's funny
conversations like this are it's all an
excuse to hang out is another sort of
Mantra of mine I'm like I'm so glad that
we could do it isn't it funny that I'm
just like check out my special on
Netflix I'm like God is
everything and if you're if you're like
freaking out cuz Pete was coming in hot
with the heavy don't worry there's like
hand job jokes and all kinds of insanity
so a l it's a good time man yeah it's on
that's on Netflix Oh on the Netflix yeah
yeah yeah yeah no the the special isn't
really like this it's it's Pete Holmes
is not for everyone it's called I am not
for everyone yeah yeah cool man uh well
I'd like to continue the conversation
not necessarily in a podcast man that
was super fun I appreciate it man thank
you uh we'll link everything up in the
show notes check out the special check
out you made it weird you've been at it
for a long time I love your show manks
good keep doing it peace right on
PL that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch
my books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcast on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale ctis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Dave Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt Trapper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plance
[Music]
namaste